Buried in a Pringles Can
Upon his death in 2008, just 20 days shy of
his 90th birthday, the inventor of the Pringles
can, Fredric J. Baur, was cremated.
In keeping with his wishes, his family placed
some of his ashes in a Pringles can (not all
of the ashes fit).
This can was then buried with most of the
rest of his remains placed in a traditional
urn.
A second urn also contained a small portion
of his remains which were given to one of
Baur’s grandchildren, rather than buried.
Baur had first made this odd burial request
to his kids back in the 1980s.
After his death, his kids decided to honor
his earlier request that they weren’t originally
quite sure if he was joking about.
So on the way to the funeral home to collect
the ashes, the family stopped off at Walgreens
and purchased a can of Pringles.
“My siblings and I briefly debated what
flavor to use,” said the son of Fredric
Baur, Larry, “but I said, ‘Look, we need
to use the original.'”
Dr. Fredric Baur was also the one that originally
came up with the “saddle” shape (hyperbolic
paraboloid) of the fried dough that is Pringles
(note: not baked, as many seem to think).
While employed by Proctor & Gamble as chemist,
he was assigned the task of finding a way
to get around the problem of stale and broken
chips in bags and thus worked on finding an
alternative “chip” and container.
However, he was not the one to ultimately
bring Pringles out as a commercial product.
The “chip” he came up with just didn’t
taste very good and he was eventually assigned
a different task.
Several years later, Alexander Liepa picked
up where Baur left off and managed to improve
on the flavor of the fried dough.
Thus, he is generally considered the inventor
of Pringles, even though he borrowed heavily
from Baur’s work.
It should be noted, though, that the product
the two came up with is not actually a potato
“chip” (or “crisp” for those of us
from the U.K.), despite the original name:
“Pringles Newfangled Potato Chips”.
You see, Pringles contain only about 42% potato
based content, with most of the rest being
from wheat starch and various types of flour,
including from corn and rice.
Thus, the U.S. Food and Drug Administration
made them change the name.
If they wanted to continue to use “chip”,
they were only allowed to say “Pringles
Potato Chips Made From Dried Potatoes”.
Not being too fond of this requirement, the
company changed the name slightly, using “potato
crisps”, rather than “potato chips”.
Today, of course, most people just know them
as “Pringles”.
While Proctor & Gamble initially argued that
Pringles were in fact “chips” in the U.S.,
they took a different tact in the U.K.
In order to avoid a 17.5% Value Added Tax
(VAT) in the U.K., Proctor & Gamble stated
that Pringles should be considered a cake,
rather than a “crisp”.
Their argument was that since only 42% of
the product was made from potato and the fact
that it is fashioned from dough, that it should
be considered a cake and not be subject to
the tax put on chips.
After all, that’s why the U.S. Food and
Drug Administration had previously made them
change from being a chip to a “crisp”.
The company initially won in High Court and
Pringles were briefly considered a cake in
the U.K.
However, Her Majesty’s Revenue & Customs
appealed the decision and, in 2009, the ruling
was reversed and the company had to start
paying the VAT.
Bonus Fact:
• Dr. Baur’s Pringles can has many more
impressive uses than he could have realized.
One such use is known as a “canntena”.
Constructed properly, which is surprisingly
easy, the Pringles can combined with some
wire and a proper connector can be used to
increase WiFi or bluetooth range significantly.
For extreme range, this setup can also be
combined with a satellite dish.
For the starving photography student, Pringles
cans can also be fashioned into thrifty diffusers
for macro photography.